[Music]
[Applause]
that's what I
[Music]
know
change
spe
all right welcome to Ash Wednesday but
there are there are no ashes uh today no
one is smoking uh cigars uh because we
have a guest here who's not a big cigar
guy we won't fault him for it uh you can
support him follow him you've seen us
cover him on these debates of course his
and his I guess dunks as people call it
uh with the media uh
v224 you can follow him not on Twitter
but on x uh we have the link up there
below uh Mr VC thank you for being here
sir it's good to be here man I'm glad to
have you I'm not saying your last name
because I I feel like I'll screw it up
yeah you can say it it's s right ramas
Swami I don't want
to I trust you I trust you I think you
do Ram Swami yeah I believe in you was
that was that right that's dead on okay
but it's VI I said the thing it's like
like cake all right but I've I've lived
this for my whole life best efforts I'm
good with best efforts right yeah do you
ever use it to screw with people to act
like you're ended if they get it wrong
like I can't you know that's a good one
I'll add to my Arsenal it will be very
it'll be very disarming to the left I
think actually I can't believe that you
pronoun like oh my go like I'm just
kidding uh which actually you know a way
to break the ice for you may not be
familiar with this we've been following
you for a while we actually have a
segment uh called The Flying V and we
have a stinger which this is the very
first time that uh Flying V is going to
see it I'm pump to see it let's let him
see it
[Applause]
good come
[Music]
on we Spar no we Spar no expense no
expense at all that's amazing yeah I
mean but it's good because every time
you would do something great Med we love
it we'd play it with that yeah uh and
then every and then everyone just went
off and it became a knuckle Puck time
people I'm sure that people will send in
the memes we can take your chats but all
right I'm pretty pumped let me ask you
first uh because there's I think now
it's uh is it 1,800 people running for
the Republican primary yeah and growing
yes why do you want and everyone else
and we'll get specific yeah you had a
moment when was that moment you said I
need to run for president last December
really yeah okay so I had i' come off of
my second book that I had written I go
through these phases so I started a
series of businesses okay was that
nation of victims I know victims was my
second book yeah and so I was on the
book tour for nation of victims and it
is kind of a you know first you take as
a compliment but then you take it
seriously where you're giving speeches
to audiences about your book I'm running
a new business that I had launched and
gotten off the ground called strive and
yet people are coming up to you
afterwards and saying hey you should
really run for president next year okay
the first time that happens you know
whatever yeah you're like thanks Mom but
if there's exactly exactly and then and
then and then on from there actually the
funny thing is my parents are the
biggest opponents of my doing this
they're probably just still disappointed
that you're not a doctor they still are
yeah they're still going through going
through psychological therapy for the
fact that the one son that didn't go to
med school that's me is doing this
craziness and the other son who did go
to med school didn't practicing it's
never too late it is well you know they
they can hold out hope but there's
always the grandkids now I think they've
turned to the running for president no
it's a big deal I think I think it's
very clear they would certainly they
made it clear at the very beginning that
um if they had a veto on it they would
exercise The veto but yeah well I don't
blame them just on the sense of like no
one wants to want my kids to go through
it either yeah but you look at it
differently for your kids versus for
yourself right so so the idea was
playing in my head but I think I saw the
red wave that never came that was
probably the Catalyst asking myself
what's the Gap in the Republican Party
there's a bunch of people who have
become practiced at criticizing the
radical Biden agenda and I've done my
fair share of that but I think that's
the main reason why the Republican Party
didn't do so well last time around is
that they didn't have an agenda of their
own they didn't have an actual
affirmative Vision but could critique
from a binder all of the things that the
radical Biden left had done right which
which frankly became boring and unuseful
yeah and so my wife and I brought her
second son into the world last year I
had just launched a new business it was
a whirlwind of a year but we took a big
step back and just sometimes you ask
yourself the question of why right I
mean why even bother doing the things
we're doing right now writing these
books starting strive to compete against
black rock all this stuff why
yeah and to tell you the truth you take
a step back we're only going to be here
for a short time I felt compelled I saw
a gap in the Republican Party there's an
absence of national identity in this
country we've lived the American dream
can't ask for more from this country
than the country's already given us how
am I going to make the maximal impact
and as ridiculous as that might
ordinarily sound oh I'm going to have my
impact by running for president yeah
that's actually the conclusion that I
came to because I do think it's going to
take somebody coming from a different
generation mhm to lead the Next
Generation and revive a national
identity yeah that I think young people
but frankly all people in this country
are badly missing and my wife asked me
if she being the same person in a
relationship asked me a reasonable
question which is okay even if you want
to do this if we want to do this are you
sure you don't want to wait 20 years
from now when our kids are out of the
house when maybe you have some more
experience and that was fair too and so
that had me pause pretty seriously you
know in the early part of the year but I
think the conclusion we came to is that
I don't think we have 20 years left as a
country really I really don't yeah not
not the same country that you and I grew
up in they're careful people will say
that's pessimistic they'll say oh you
have no chance unless you do the Reagan
shining city on a hill so well it's not
mourning in America that's the point it
can be morning in America again I I do
believe that I'm inherently an optimist
actually I'm natively an optimist to a
fault but I also believe in not
filtering your optimism through a fake
prism yeah and so yeah some people will
on the Republican debate stage the
American dream is alive and well no it's
it's actually not right now it maybe on
life support that might be closer to
where it is it's not morning in America
but it can be but I think it takes
somebody who was both motivated by
something other than
just pummeling the other side into the
ground versus actually asking what are
we running to but not doing it in this
fake optimistic polyana way that
pretends like we're not in the middle of
this war that we're actually in as a
country well and it also requires
someone with some skin in the game
something to lose you know CER
politicians let's be honest these people
they never want to leave office I mean
last time uh Joe Biden saw private
office uh I think like five I think yeah
I mean I think I don't even know if we
were on the new I don't even know if we
were ad at that point the only time they
want to leave office is if they can
exploit their government connections to
actually make more money than they
otherwise would have made exactly to
which happens in both parties by way
which goes back to like you said we're
not here for a very long time he's
certainly not here for a very long time
he's 6' five they don't live very long
it doesn't matter what you do my wife's
a nurse and she text how tall are you
man h i I say 6'2 this guy's big yeah
he's 64 65 he's 65 he he a while to go
very health they don't live very healthy
I don't care how much cycling you do
with your like pants so um I think
that's important because you do have to
identify a problem in order to actually
have genuine optimism right um I think
sometimes people get it wrong when they
say the American dream is dead and
they'll talk about like the you know
price of a house or or something like
that they'll talk about you know a
pension um that their uh their parents
had the boomer generation I go when was
the last time you worked in a Foundry
right there are still like trades that
are available you have more options to
live in houses further out of the city
we have different priorities but um as
far as the idea that the world is your
oyster um and that you know you can go
out and you can do better for yourself I
do see that generationally that well
perception is reality for a lot of young
people it is yeah and we call it the
American dream you know it means
something is the way you describe
America affects the way America actually
works that's the unique fact of a
country built on ideals you know other
countries are built on let's just say a
religion or a monarch America's not
built on these things they were built on
a national set of ideals and so if you
have a group of people that decide those
ideals no longer exist that has an
underlying effect on the way the country
actually works yeah and so I do think
it's going to take somebody who's able
to reach the next generation of Young
Americans to revive that conviction in
our purpose and I don't think the
American dream is just about green
pieces of paper I mean right you know
you've achieved that perhaps through
your company in business here I've
achieved you know I've achieved my
version living the dream people look at
us like yeah you know he surviving
you're doing pretty well man I got a
tour of the place you're you're you're
you're surviving and
thriving but I don't think that that's
the whole story I don't think it's about
accumulating green pieces of paper I
think it is about
Reviving conviction in our
purpose as citizens of this nation yeah
you know right now it just feels like
we're going through this aimless passage
of time and there is more to life than
the aimless passage of time but what
happened I think some somewhere along
the way is the things that used to fill
our sense of purpose yeah and you can
fill in the blank for different people
it's different faith for many people
patriotism belief in country for many
people hard work the idea that I work
hard and create something in the world
that I'm proud of that I derive my
meaning from that maybe it's my family
when each of those things and they
have have disappeared in their
importance in our American Life yeah
that leaves this deep vacuum of purpose
and meaning in the heart of a and that's
where we are right now and you can't
fill a vacuum with a void you know
that's what we see for example a lot of
the Middle East where it's like well
hold on a second even if these people if
we try and stabilize it right and this
is something that's never really worked
you have people who were under what
would be considered radical regimes but
at least there was an ingrained ideology
these were fascists they were anti
freedom but you can't fill that void
with nothing that's right um and that's
the challeng and and and so the left is
good at this they have their
understanding of this is far deeper than
actually many conservatives they will
say we will fill that void with
something yeah not jihadism somewhere
else race gender sexuality climate which
is sort of ideological jihadism and
intellectual jihadism in this country
but at least they're doing that yeah and
I think the Trap that we have often
fallen into myself included in this if
you you know read some of the books I've
written at times I've been doing this is
criticize all that's wrong and
hypocritical with that Vision without
talking about an alternative Vision say
grounded in the individual right family
Nation God yeah I personally think that
beats race gender sexuality and climate
if we have the courage to actually stand
for it but I think that that was the
muscle memory of the modern conservative
movement was to Define ourselves in
opposition to their Vision Without
offering an actual substantive vision of
our own where we dilute their poison to
irrelevance rather than just hammering
it out of existence well I want to get
to some specifics like on the
three-letter agencies in section 230 but
it's that you you bring that up because
on a personal level you know I've talked
about is the only way you develop
self-esteem is by getting really really
good at something getting excellent I
think that's correct and something it
starts with passion it doesn't matter
what it is you just have to get really
good at something that's the only way
that you see oh wow reps work oh wow
time works it's just a certain amount of
doing it and um it goes back to okay
what is America great at doing right now
you know other Generations kind of had
that whether was World War II they had
an incredible sense of purpose you know
whether it was manufacturing speing
technology um that war whatever was
whatever it was um and that void has
been been filled with your self-esteem
is found actually in your identity
because it's it's a criticism proof yes
which I think is why it probably draws
people like you who are trying to look
for that intellectual consistency same
with me I'm going like no no no no hold
a second the emperor has no close but
you can't also fix that self-esteem
issue that has now been replaced with
identity without letting people know how
you actually gain self-respect and
purpose and so on I totally agree with
you and on an optimistic day what I will
say is the self loss of self-esteem is
right over the Target in terms of what's
going on in our country right now the
analogy I would love to draw and I think
it's
true I I hope this is true is
that maybe as a nation we're not
actually in
Decline maybe we're just going through
our version of adolescence yeah and when
you go through your adolescence you lose
your self-confidence you lose your way a
little bit yeah you do some things you
regret out of that self-confidence loss
well maybe our nation is going through
our version of adolescence but like all
of us do hopefully or many of us do we
get to our adulthood on the other side
MH and then for me I think the current
picture of what I see in the country
this would be my version of the
optimistic lens that I bring to the
table not just some sort of slogan
written recite of reaganism and say it's
morning in America right but maybe maybe
it's possible that we're just in the
thick of that adolescence yeah but we
will get to our adulthood on the other
side and we don't have to be that nation
in Decline maybe we're still early in
our ascent so let me ask you before we
because we covered these debates right
we did the the two debates but these
live streams um and you know it seemed
like there was a start contrast between
the first one where you did come out
aggressive and afterward you said hey
everyone on the stage you know they're
they're good people it seemed much more
amicable I would say that for most
people on the stage yeah most even Chris
Christie well you know he's he's got his
he's got his thing he's got his got his
stick thing is not being one of the good
people the well for me for me my the
real thing I have a problem with is
Republican or Democrat people who make
money off their public service right and
will further Advance policies to line
their own Pockets yeah and you know we
don't we have so many more important
things to discuss than to assail
individuals on that stage that exists in
the Republican party including in this
race but I think most of them are good
people tainted by a broken system right
okay so I'm not running against any of
those individuals I'm running against a
broken system and I have come to this
conclusion with firm conviction in a way
that if you asked me a few years ago I
wouldn't have said it was a problem in
the same way the super Pacs are a Cancer
on Politics on American politics and the
Republican party and Democrat Party
alike and I should have come to this
conclusion earlier because my crusade
against do you guys talk about the ESG
movement or does that yeah oh yeahi so I
mean one of my so my last business
before I ran for president was this
company called strive which offers index
funds basic low fee ways to invest in
the stock market or index funds index
funds that are similar to those offered
by Black Rock and Stat St and Vanguard
but without pushing these environmental
and social agendas onto the underlying
companies when they vote their shares
now why why do I care about this one of
the reasons I care about this is I think
that the way things work in the United
States of America they're supposed to
work is that we the people settle our
differences on questions from climate
change to racial Injustice to whatever
through a constitutional republic where
every Citizen's voice and vote counts
equally and the ESG movement rejects
that because it says that Larry thinkink
the CEO of Black Rock gets to decide
that from the Park Avenue corner office
in Manhattan right and then Elizabeth
Warren socialist and chief gets to say
oh they're too big to fail EX on the
Socialist but but when got right right
and it's a merger of state and corporate
power and that whole game and and so the
left when I wrote woke Inc which was my
first book and even when I started
strive some people some thoughtful
Critics on the left would come up to me
and say okay well well where are you on
Citizens United and my response at the
time right was at the time and i' I've
evolved a little bit on this from having
seen this can I really quickly jump in
here because a lot of people don't
realize this was the left and I used to
combat them or they say citizens united
businesses are not people I was going
well hold on a second though the ruling
of citizens united was basically the
Hillary Clinton the Clinton machine
wanted to stop a negative documentary
against Hillary Clinton from out so
initially I'm going hold a second these
filmmakers even though they're a
business have the right to free speech
that's right um and that's probably
where started off with a defense point
and then saw it met and I'm I'm a free
speech Advocate and so we can put the
legal holding in the First Amendment
holding of citizens united and just
respect that we have a First Amendment
in this country and we have to have a
world in which people can criticize
politicians or those who rise to power
but my response to the left so they they
would say that you're inconsistent
because you're not calling out the
actual influence of super packs on
electoral politics where everybody's
Citizens Voice and vote doesn't count
equal but you're only focusing on this
ESG thing because it's politically
popular for you because you're on the
right I I don't think of myself as a
traditional partisan anyway but I said
you know that felt to me like the bigger
problem was the use of capital
retirement funds trillions tens of
trillions of dollars of our own money
probably the money of people watching
this program that don't know it that are
being being used to vote for toxic
left-wing policies in corporate
America's boardrooms that's the real
cancer and it is a cancer however I
think that now that I have a close
proximity to politics which I didn't
have then I came from the business world
where I realized what a big problem that
was there I have moved a little bit to
now believe that you know what the Super
PAC influence on our electoral politics
absolutely is a big problem and if that
was a leftwing concern 13 years ago so
be it right it ought to be an America
First conservative concern today M and
so my view is that it's going to take
somebody who's independent of that to
break that system right one of things
I've learned is every politician and and
I've met a lot of politicians not just
presidential candidates at every level
every politician is gross is gross and
dances to the tune of their biggest
donor it's like a circus monkey yeah so
so that's just like as the sun rises in
the East and sets in the west kind of
thing it's like a law of physics in my
case and in a rare few other cases that
biggest donor is me right and so that
brings with it a special sense of
responsibility and so I'm thinking about
as this race evolves
I part of me has a deep-seated
irritation mhm with respect to the other
professional politicians in this
Republican primary and the Democrat race
as well and Joe Biden and everything
else but the part of me now that
realizes these people are just vessels
right they're really just vehicles for
advancing the interests of what the guy
or gal who wrote their biggest check
wanted them to say I can't even hold it
against them they don't have many cases
independent thoughts oh I can they're
offering they're but they're not even I
mean I think of them as literally as
just vessels Vehicles it's the system
that I'm running against at the same
time sometimes it's a two-way
relationship some of them will also make
personal money off of it and it becomes
a two-way incestuous relationship that's
what I'm against I think it's a fair
point to say that they're vessels and I
I was I have to be very honest during
the first debate I was cheering you on
because I was like you're making great
points these guys are trying to talk
over you you're doing a great job in the
second debate I was yelling at the
camera because I'm like you're trying to
make friends with these people is what
it seemed like and I'm like it feel like
that a little bit app trying to pull out
the the the partis just got to be
yourself a Republicans was look look it
was there
was a sense of being in the Reagan
Library it was framed as we're going to
have a policy debate there's six people
talking at the same time and what was
effectively an unmoderated and the
knives were out though the knives and
the bad jokes Donald Duck yeah yeah it
was it wasn't it wasn't great it was a
terrible joke so so I think that the
truth
is I'm finding Clarity in in terms of
what I'm actually running against I'm
running against the Puppet Masters who
are putting up these puppets on that
stage yeah at the same
time there's no point in trying to meld
over some sort of yeah you know we don't
really disagree on that much policy we
disagree on a few policies but these are
people who are effectively being wielded
and manipulated by a super pack puppetry
system that I think I I need to more or
less take my gloves off and go after
directly because the idea of trying to
play nice or how do you fix that yeah
one of the ways to fix it is I mean you
can just do it in the context of this
race I said look I'm in this to win this
but I would give up and publicly call on
technically you know these are a
separate parallel system but I would
publicly call on any super pack
supporting me and say give that money
back to those Mega donors and I won't
show up at your events or anything else
as long as every other Republican
candidate in the race pledges to do the
same thing or at least the ones who
matter you know Ronda s Nikki Haley at
least maybe Tim Scott who is all of whom
are basically funded by super Pacs it's
a joke that your campaign is actually
being run by your campaign it's not this
is the superpac primary where the people
who can write unlimited checks are
wielding these people as PS okay well
that won't happen though so do you have
do you have a plan B yeah look so so I
think from a policy perspective now now
I got to win to be able to do this my
view is there is already a regime that
says there are limits on how much you
can directly contribute to a campaign so
my view is do you have free speech
rights absolutely you do but if it's to
promotee a particular candidate to
effectively either run campaign
operations door- knocking operations to
out signs for Ronda sis or whatever just
everybody's subject to the same rules
what do most viewers of this program are
they told $3,300 is the maximum you can
give to an individual candidate well
then why should somebody else be able to
give $30 million but get special
political favors out of it right now we
have a free speech issue fine policy
whatever policy or cultural view you
want to address great we already have a
regime that limits the amount you can
give to a candidate so we've already
accepted that's not a constraint on free
the only one arrested for it was Des D
Souza who gave it to a friend running
for a senate race that I don't know the
specifics of that case but I'm sure it
was applied even handedly regard of
their political beliefs under President
Obama I'm sure it was I'm sure he was
you know politically suffering at the
cost of his views but that's why I think
the system should work right $3,300 Max
and you know per per primary per General
so $6,600 that's the current regime
that's a lot of money for a lot of
people for sure
but it's not going to be to BU off a
politician at the federal level that's
why we have that regim so you have the
separate regime should somebody be able
to create a film that offers a criticism
of Hillary Clinton's policies or
somebody else's policies or stands for a
particular agenda whether or not agree
with it absolutely should there be
limits on how much money they can invest
in that absolutely not right but if
they're going to use it as a campaign
contribution or a constructive campaign
contribution in propping up a specific
candidate by name in the exact same
format as a political ad specifically
advocating for an individual candidate
apply the same rules that you do for you
just brought up a very interesting
problem to when we're talking about
Hillary Clinton documentary well no
one's saying that Michael Moore can't
raise as much money as he wants right
we're talking private investment this is
a problem that also happens in
conservative media every major
conservative media outlet and this is
why we started mug Club in our Network
they all have a 501c3 and they all have
a 501c4 and ironically the left is very
effective at doing this through free
enterprise right they as far left as but
Hollywood right at the end of the day
dollars sense um and the right is far
more reliant on nonprofit donors for
even and for even media content yeah
it's interesting I I was aware of that
so so you guys have a C3 arm as well oh
you don't do that we do not no we do not
and there's a big reason that this is a
big thing that we've uh had a lot of
conflict with where there are a lot of
um unfortunately conservatives out there
who have to play ball by YouTube's
guidelines and by Facebook's guidelines
um because donors want to make sure
they're still yeah exactly it's you know
hopefully you'll kill me last and they
never do um and that's why we're
entirely funded by uh by mug club by
independent about you guys know where to
sign up capitalism it's not PBS where we
say that and then take money from the
federal government but that is one thing
that you'll be you will be up against
just so you know because these same
people who give to the giant packs also
give to the 501 C4s of these giant media
enties totally and it's a it's a choked
system and so part of the reason I'm
able to say some of the things that I'm
able to say pardon peaceful Gen 6
protesters that I'm against the war in
Ukraine continuing and against further
us funding I mean go down my views on
the climate agenda lot of people on the
conservative side of the aisle making
good money off of those subsidies coming
from on high from the Biden
Administration the reason I'm able to
take these views is precisely because it
doesn't align with the donor
establishment but still I'm able to be
Joe Le he if he's distracted Joe which
is incredibly he never barks at anything
so someone's probably being murdered out
there true he's the most mellow no no
I'm say he never barks when was the last
time we heard him bark uh so let's go
back to Black Rock you're kind of
talking about this um this does seem to
be the sort of amalgamate right you have
have these giant companies right that
are uh quote unquote sort of taking away
the American dream even if you look into
housing totally you look into housing
you look into wanting to create an
entire generation of of renters right
own nothing and like it and then of
course big Tech which determines what
you can and can't say and also
determines what people can and cannot
learn and the government determining the
winners and losers in those spaces um
how do you take that on how do you do it
now unfortunately it inol it involves
government intervention but not to the
same degree elizeth War wants to say too
big to fail so that they have control
well the way I look at it is let's
actually roll back the government
intervention that created a lot of those
behemoths in the first place so you want
to go big Tech direction or Black Rock
let's let's go big Tech first because
big first okay because black rock is
kind of easy everyone can say black rock
opioid epidemic you know what I mean
everyone goes yeah we don't like that
but let's talk about big I think there's
a lot to say there but I've been I've
been and Vanguard and Mackenzie and
Company right that's that's been the
last several years of my life so we can
go there yeah we'll go big Tech first so
these you take the three largest
financial institutions Black Rock State
Street Vanguard or you want to take
Facebook Google or meta Google whatever
these are the most powerful companies in
human history more than the Dutch East
India Company y back in the day which
couldn't decide what you do or don't say
to express yourself right now why are
they so powerful part of the reason why
in both cases we'll get to the Black
Rock case too is government intervention
to create special privileges that these
that these companies effectively enjoy
now this dates back a long time I know
that you all have paid attention to the
section 230 debate that's one example
yeah of a crony capitalist privilege
conferred on a special class of
companies that the rest of the country
or the rest of the industries don't
enjoy right so my view is you can't have
it both ways either you get special
governmental Protections in which case
you are bound by the same constraints
applied to the government namely the US
Constitution or you don't get those
constraints and you're free to decide
whatever it is you want to do exactly
but you can't have both and so what what
happens today is these tech companies
are effectively making political
decisions I mean you all experience this
about what kind of content can and
cannot appear on the internet that
violate the First Amendment but the
thing that people used to say four years
ago is oh you know if you said that oh
you're a Rube the First Amendment only
applies to the government it doesn't
apply to to state actors doesn't apply
to private companies well not so fast
there if it is State action in disguise
right if the government is giving a
special blanket of protection to a class
of companies to do exactly what they're
doing MH then if it's state action in
Disguise the Constitution still applies
and so one easy example sometimes you
get out of the present and you go to the
Past a little bit go to history you can
come back to the present and see it more
clearly there was this heavy debate
about the ra railroad companies during
the War on Drugs version 1.0 of it at
least where they wanted to search and
seize individual passengers for whether
or not they had drugs on them the
inconvenient part of this for the
government is that there's this pesky
thing called the fourth amendment that
says you can't quite do that yeah so
what the government did they got clever
they said okay we're going to pass a
statute that says that we're not going
to search and seize anything the
government police forget about it we're
just going to say the railroad can't be
sued if they do that for one of their
employees are passengers so what do the
railroads do they start searching and
seizing and you they can do that with at
the be of the government though not of
the government not with just the
incentive you're saying they went behind
the scenes probably and said hey guys
it' be really nice if you did this well
well the funny thing is in this
particular case in the big Tech case you
get the you get the incentive too but in
this you get the back door goting too in
this case it literally was just the
incentive and so this went to the
Supreme Court and the Supreme Court said
the incentive alone right the the loss
of immunity alone was enough to say that
the railroad companies couldn't do that
that was State action in disguise right
so now in the tech case not only do you
have section 230 which does the same
thing which says that if you take down
section 230 C2 in particular people pay
attention to C1 C2 is the part that says
if you take down content that is
otherwise constitutionally permissible
that you can do that with impunity even
though there are some laws at the states
that say you can't engage in political
discrimination right about half the
states in this country have such a law
this says no no no for a tech company
that operat it's an internet website you
don't have that same liability it
overrides any liability you might have
under that state law right so it's the
same thing as with the railroads but
with the tech companies it's one step
worse not only do they do that they're
also holding a gun to your head and
saying that if you don't take down that
speech yeah we're going to break you up
we're going to penalize you we're going
to regulate you and so on it's even more
corrosive because both in this case it's
even it's even a stronger case than it
was against the railroads well and there
were you know there were only a handful
of railroad companies you know in back
in the day because it was very expensive
but the issue with big Tech right A lot
of people having been there since 2006
for example on YouTube my brother was
one of the first original Partners it
was hey this is going to break apart the
strangle hold that really only five
companies on Earth as far as media you
know hold abcc CBS you know Viacom
Turner and uh so independent creators
flocked to these platforms because they
could make a living and now those same
people are saying hey great we brought
in all The Independents only now um
we've eliminated competition we can tell
you what you can and can't say and then
even further down the line you have a
company like Rumble who is being banned
by foreign governments being banned for
simply allowing speech on the platform
and they're the only company that's
really had the balls to say okay they
flipped the bird to all of France y um
and the UK recently and the UK and you
have a lot of conservatives who are
afraid to touch it so I Do by the way
little known you know the railroad who
are afraid to touch it meaning they're
afraid they're still afraid to touch it
and really go after big Tech and YouTube
and Facebook like there's a lot of talk
and there's not there's been nothing
done since I've been around I think this
goes back to the other effect of
lobbying through capture right it's the
oldest trick in the book use government
as a tool as a mode
to stop somebody from being able to
compete against you and so my view is
one of the solutions to all of this
doesn't come from government at all it
comes through competition in the market
I actually you guys may not know this I
I invested in Rumble back when it was a
private company right precisely because
I believed in competition to Google
Google and YouTube yeah that's also why
I started strive to compete against
black rock look we can complain about
the powers that be but let's create
Market Alternatives that people are
actually able the challenge there though
is they have such an advantage and such
a leg up at this point you so so so so
so I'm not there's no Panacea there's no
silver bullets it's an all of the- above
approach but if we're just relying on
government where you don't have people
with actual capabilities to compete well
that doesn't really solve the market
Choice problem on the other hand the
market Choice problem alone against the
backdrop of government created
protections that these companies enjoy
that's also not going to on its own
solve the problem until you actually
overcome the scale advantage that the
existing incumbents have you know take
the Black Rock example the reason Black
Rock State St and Vanguard manage you
know 20 trillion plus amongst the three
firms alone that's about as much worth
as the US GDP in the hands of three
firms yeah is that Pension funds
particularly Blue State Pension funds in
New York and California those are arms
of the
government invest trillions of dollars
with these asset managers and they
further tell them that we won't invest
that money with you unless you embrace
the goals of the Paris climate Accords
unless you adopt diversity Equity
inclusion standards not just at your
firm but vote your shares accordingly in
any of the underlying firms that you're
investing in so that's directly using
government controlled money of the of
the taxpayer of the pensioner to do
through the back door what government
couldn't get done through the front door
so it's the same movie as we're seeing
with censoring speech as we now see with
the weaponization of capital through
Capital markets and so that's the real
threat to Liberty that we face today not
just big government not 1980 anymore
it's this hybrid of big government and
big bus that together are able to do
what neither one could alone and we
require leaders who
recognize that new threat rather than
just reciting slogans that we memorized
back in 1980 that's the death where I
would say of the quote unquote American
dream I still think there there are a
lot of possibilities and I do think that
a lot of people are entitled
generationally but yeah this Leviathan
that is both big government and these
big businesses who the way could not
have scaled to that degree without the
assistance of government yeah they
actually are beholden to acting uh
outside of the best interest of the
American people people Black Rock and
Vanguard you cannot be both loyal to the
Constitution of the United States of
America and the Paris uh climate Accord
I always go kotto protocol Paris by the
way which by the way the US pulled out
of right so it was when Trump pulled out
of the Paris climate Accords that these
people then said okay we're going to get
it done through the back door using your
Capital without you knowing it as a
vehicle to actually do it so I think
that lays out the answer to a question
that a lot of people I think are
probably when I travel this country
certainly wonder
about I do think we're in the middle of
a kind of war in this country it is a
war between the majority of us who love
this country and what we're founded on
and love the founding ideals of this
country and believe that all men are
created equal and that you get ahead not
in the color of your skin but on the
content of your character the basic
American Creeds we know to be true most
of us who share those values in common
and then this Fringe minority and I do
think it's a fringe minority in the
country that believe that your identity
is based on your your race your gender
your sexuality that you have to abandon
carbon emissions here in the United
States even if you ship them shift them
to places like China but the mystery is
why is this other
side winning that war when it's a fringe
minority that well because we say Fringe
minority but you can't name one member
of the national platform of the DNC
doesn't actively support they have the
Democratic party in a choke cold but but
they have every major institution in a
choke cold right every technology
company every asset management firm
every educational institution K through
12 or or universities I mean even our
own military and and part of what's
going on here is that take each of these
institutions what do they have in common
it's
something that you got to go beneath the
surface to see it Wall Street okay
Occupy Wall Street occupied Wall Street
after the' 08 crisis the criticism came
from the left the original version of
breakup big Tech back in the early 2000s
and even to the early 2010s came from
the left the criticism of the Iraq War
and the Afghanistan war came from the
left so you go through institution one
by one these used to be institutions
that took their main criticism from the
old left and so what ended up happening
one institution after another all the
way up to an including our own military
let alone Wall Street to Silicon Valley
which we were talking about before is
they realized that they could
defang the old left mhm if they adopted
and used their own corporate power or
use their own managerial power in the
case of the military or otherwise to fo
the new left's chosen ideology on
everybody so that's what black rock is
doing because the old version they said
Occupy Wall Street well I don't want to
do that I don't want my only criticism
there would be that the Tea Party came
well before Occupy Wall Street after the
Santelli rant where he was the one who
said this is what you get too big to
fail with that famous 2008 crash and
that was preoccupied I will say that I
will say that the tea party this well
let's let's go through the actual timing
of this so the bailouts were made under
the Bush Administration yeah for talking
about the initial tarp yeah it's
absolutely this is the original sin of
the the bailouts right yeah and so the
original version of what became Occupy
Wall Street later the leftwing reaction
the leftwing position right even in that
election in the 2008 election Ian John
McCain I think he would have won that
election if he had criticized the
bailouts but he came out like but the
tea party was a right popul movement
that did criticize it and there was
there was a big Schism there between
like the bush for the 2010 run no no
this was preoccupied Wall Street this
was this it didn't have any impact when
the 2008 election was lost across the
board right but I'm just saying that the
Tea Party came out and protested the
idea of the big Banks and big to fail
before and I and I say that because I
was there and I thought man this is a if
there could be common ground you would
think the initial tea party occupy W and
actually was in New York I went to some
of those tea party meetings back then
too so I know I know what you're I know
what you're referring to but I would say
broadly speaking
what you saw was forget left or right
even if you're black rock or if you're
Facebook or if you're Google or if
you're the US military who are the
people criticizing me for the war in
Iraq or for the bailouts or for the you
know or for the agglomeration of
Monopoly power and big Tech yeah what do
I say to appease most of them you know
the teep party okay we're not going to
get them but mostly the rest of the
Occupy Wall Street movement what are we
going to say we'll put token minorities
on your boards we'll Muse about the
racially disperate impact of climate
change as long as we still get to fly in
a private jet to Davos to say it yes and
that was the trade that effectively
allowed this Fringe minority by numbers
in the United States you know ask most
people in this country they don't share
these views but to be able to capture
the managerial class that still wields
power over every major institution in
American life that is how the other side
is winning this war and so if we're to
recapture control of this country and
institutions in and outside of
government we have to stand that
arranged marriage yeah that Mutual
prostitution of these two strange
bedfellows that one agreed to advance
the ideology as a sort of vessel as long
as they got what they needed to out of
that trade and I think that's a big part
of what happened roughly I mean there's
a different version of the story in
different I think you're right I think
but it happened in every sphere of
American Life the Tea Party had that
midterm sort of Red Wave politically and
Occupy Wall Street had the cultural and
economic impact like you're talking
about with with ESG and Dei right these
are sort of these I guess you would say
cancerous growths that come from there
because I was down there too the dowy
yeah I was down there Z Park and like I
was yes I was sitting there and I'm
going okay Occupy Wall Street and then I
see Hammers and sickles you know and Cha
uh and KL marks I'm going oh okay so you
want I guess you're saying that too big
to fail is a problem you want to
nationalize everything okay this is
where I get off uh get off on this stop
the logic train isn't stopping here but
uh we should have been able to find some
common also quick note the rail there
was a great book maybe we can now I mean
even on the super back question right
now the old left it's it's interesting
now that I've taken up this message I'm
not hearing many on the left rise up and
join me because Biden's election
re-election campaign is absolutely going
to be run by the same apparatus that's
running most of the other Republicans
which is the Super PAC apparatus but it
should in principle be an issue that
transcends traditional well there was a
lot of overlap between Donald Trump and
Bernie Sanders and I say this is someone
who I mean mercilessly mocked Bernie
Sanders but we had a lot of people once
Bernie dropped out once he was screwed
let's say out of the primaries a lot of
them came over and they became Trump
supporters and that surprised me was
back then we have a large sample size
right because we have so much as far as
what comes in through back then Google
and my own website we're going oh wow a
lot of these people were really mad at
me for criticizing uh Bernie and his
praising of Karl Marx and socialist
policies but now they've come back
because they see a rebel so an outsider
in Donald Trump and that was a you want
to know what something funny this is
even just a rift on the left I mean
we're here we're you know we would
consider ourselves on the right but it's
interesting to observe even a fissure
there on the left so bringing up the
Occupy Wall Street in the 2012 version
of this there was this video I talked
about this in my first book woking I
can't remember where it was I want to
say it was in one of the occupied Wall
Street movements in Philadelphia cuz it
spread out in New York where there was
this event everybody showing up pissed
off at the system against the big banks
that are that are taking our money
redistribution from Rich to poor that's
what we're standing for and so this guy
takes the microphone but he's a white
man and they say Hey you have to stand
step up and stand back MH he said what
does that mean well there's an
intersectional High hierarchy where they
decided that actually if you were black
and a woman you got to the front of the
line in terms of when you got called on
and this guy was coming ready to rail
against the system right because he was
the one oppressed against and and you
could just see in his face but wait a
minute I was going to be the one who was
going to be the one who's complaining
about the big Bank screwing us out of
all of our money but now she gets to be
the one who complains about and she
didn't know she was supposed to complain
she's like I guess I'm up micone right
so that was that was kind of a fissure
between you know Bernie has has kind of
moved and and kind of bent the knee a
little bit to the woke mob too but the
version of just the economic
redistributionist left that gave way to
this new intersectional hierarchy the
woke oppression identity identitarian
version of it that was sort of a weird
fissure even on the left that you know
the Wall Streets of the world they
didn't want the economic
redistributionist to necessarily be the
ones they were debating but the
identitarians that want to talk about
climate change we'll do that all day
because we can just check a box and it's
easy for us to do yeah and so that was
that was sort of the way that played out
and that also brings us to kind of of
the enforcement of this you talk about
this sort of these these strange bed
fellows I mean they're so strange at
that point it' be like you know the
Hellraiser budoir at that point um it is
yeah awful but the enforcement of course
doesn't take place without the
three-letter agencies that's right this
is the ultimate version of the
managerial class in the swamp and so
when I'm thinking about what do I want
to do as US president shut down that
administrative state in its entire
apparatus now this has been talked about
for a long time by Trump and otherwise
and people all the way back to Reagan I
think it's going to take a unique
combination of traits to do it mhm it's
going to take a CEO an outsider coming
in saying that you know what if somebody
works for you and you can't fire them
yeah that means they don't work for you
right it means you work for them because
you're responsible for what they do
without any authority to change it so
that's on the one hand but on the other
it's going to take an outsider who also
understands the law and the constitution
in a deep way and let's just make a
basic observation here those two
characteristics
don't go well together right because on
one hand you have an academic that might
be pontificating about the law and the
Constitution but doesn't have the sharp
elbows to get something done on the
other you might have a sharp elbowed guy
he's going to say I'm going to break the
system but doesn't understand why he's
going through the motions he
does and this is how they duped Trump in
many ways they told him that you can't
fire those people because there are
civil service protections right well if
you read the law you realize those Civil
Service protections only apply to
individual firings right the logic is if
you work at I don't know FTC and I
disagree with you on abortion I
shouldn't be able to fire you if I'm the
president agree or not that's what the
rules are made to do right but they do
not apply to mass layoffs mhm so that's
the key Mass layoffs are absolutely what
I am bringing to the DC bureaucracy 75%
head count reduction by the end of the
first term over a million in the first
year 50% of that taking place in year
one people can find honest work in the
private sector I'm told that there's
more open jobs than there are people
looking for work this is a two for one
if we want it right test that theory
absolutely let's let's let's put some
people to some actual honest work and
grow the economy agencies that should
not exist Department of Education FBI
IRS ATF nuclear Regulatory Commission
CDC which I know you like to
quote got well well uh even though I
know you you may like to quote it we're
still going to shut it down I'm actually
okay with that you're okay with that
another so that's another so you're
sharp elbowed enough to do
it I think you need to have somebody who
has a complete and total disregard
Washington DC and its Norms yes well but
it's also for your own popularity
because look we're talking about the
most popular agencies not popular I
guess powerful is the right term in the
United States and maybe in the world not
popular sorry sorry wrong p word
powerful agencies like that that's
that's risky right I me obviously you've
had to have like these kind of okay like
I'm doing some pretty big things there
are going to be some people that don't
want me to succeed at doing this and
nobody's been able to successfully do
this maybe it's because they haven't
tried but
there's Christie has called this the
dumbest idea that he's ever heard was to
shut down the FBI I disagree yeah I
respectfully disagree you I think this
dumbest idea I've ever heard is when
they found uh how many terabytes of
pedophile pornography on CIA computers
that there were no Mass layoffs unbel
and yet these are the same apparatus
that supposed to be going after it yeah
exactly on the other side it's so
disturbing like how about at what point
do you say oh okay you cease to exist
because you're committing the grossest
evil this is this is where other people
and it annoys the heck out of me when I
see other Republicans we're going to I
mean we're going to get in there and
fire Christopher Ray and like try to act
like a tough guy what is that going to
do come on you're that's what it is
that's that's all and and you're trying
to use some emotionally and I see these
people behind the backstage before the
debates man it's I mean it's really sad
but then comes on there's I will fire
Christopher Ray and to what end because
you're going to get James Comey 2.0 the
machine is what the rot is all about
that is the Leviathan now this is also
very practical for me you can't just
offer slogans say shut down the FBI I'm
serious about this 35,000 employees work
at the FBI the failed Bureau of
Investigation it is still by the way the
Jed G Hoover building that people walk
into in Washington DC can you believe
this it is still honoring his legacy the
same guy who collected tapes and
threatened Martin Luther King with
suicide the same guy that's now going
after concerned parents calling them
domestic terrorists that's still the
same Legacy they're celebrating 35,000
employees 20,000 of them are bureaucrats
in back office functions which is where
the rot and the corruption comes from
15,000 of them are agents on the front
lines I say put those agents where they
will be more effective the US Marshals
have actually been far more effective in
going after child trafficking and
related cases than the FBI has Fine move
some of the 15,000 there we've laid out
a clear plan to do this you know
Financial crimes complex white collar
crimes people FBI have no clue what
they're doing because the guy who's
doing child trafficking today is doing
counterterrorism the next day and is
doing Financial crimes the day after
that there's no specialization anyway
move them there's a separate part of the
treasury called the financial crime
enforcement Network so move people to
the exact places where they can
precisely do their jobs and it's not a
coincidence that when you have the loss
of that specialization and the over
bureaucratization that's when you see
the corruption so it's not like we're
getting happening to get lucky solving
two problems at once the two problems go
hand and glove together the
ineffectiveness and the bureaucratic
bloat is itself a formula for the
corruption because you have a bunch of
people shown up to work that shouldn't
have been at work they find things to do
that they shouldn't have been doing yeah
and so yes it's going to take somebody
who is willing to get in there and got
it incremental reform will not work fire
Christopher Ray is a false premise it is
a false lie you're being lied to and
their their job is to dup you they're
trying to distract you to make you feel
like they did something and they didn't
he's a symptom uh just as I would even
say that bureaucratic bloat is a all
those things are symptoms of one thing a
complete lack of accountability other
words you only get that bloat with a
complete lack of accountability we have
87,000 we want to be sure that we're not
fact checked on YouTube 87,000 new
employees to the IRS not all our agents
right that's the word play then what do
they do you're really you guys have you
guys are very good I mean that's they'll
catch you they'll suspend us for that if
you say agents and not 87,000 employees
it'd be interesting if they applied that
same standard to the CNN clips that end
up online they don't it's really funny
I've had my experiences with those guys
yeah well that was one of the first
places that I saw you when you were
talking to CNN and I think it was about
there was some ethnic conversation that
you were having with somebody who oh it
was a was it Don Lemon yeah who pulled
his ear now guys get out of my
ear but it was one of those moments
where like all right
somebody well and that's one of the
things that resonated with the American
people about Donald Trump is that he was
ready to say things that a lot of people
thought and he just didn't care about
the niceties of politics he didn't care
about saying something that sounded good
now you can have your problems with
President Trump that's fine I understand
that but that's the thing that I think a
lot of people saw in you as well and
said okay somebody's coming in from the
outside that might be able to get
something done that's what's going to
take the biggest question though is okay
people have tried it before why are you
different than a president Trump was
because he even had some problems
getting everything he did a lot of great
things I think he did a lot of and you
said that so I appreciate that I think
he's an excellent president I mean
everybody else is trying to Monday
Morning Quarterback some small thing
that he did they feel like they have to
which is senseless yeah when in fact he
was a great president now how do we move
this agenda forward that's my question
so a few things I think it will take I
said we're in a
war all else equel who's going to be the
general that moves us forward in that
war all else equel it's better to have a
general who has yet been wounded in that
war mhm I have fresh legs I'm 38 I'm
less I think it's less than half a
Trump's age now my question is what what
are you going to do with the last half
of your 40s goodness what's next
after I'm I'm not a plan plan b or a
plan after kind of guy we've got the
next mission lined up and we'll figure
out what comes after after but I do
think it will take somebody from the
Next Generation to reach that next
generation and I think we can do that in
a way that Trump you know is of a
different generation it's going to be a
lot harder for him to do that job I also
think we can pick up where he left off I
mean I'm not saying that I would have
been able to do everything I'm telling
you we're going to do if Trump hadn't
laid the groundwork part of the reason
that we I can confidently tell you we
will be able to without asking Congress
for permission or for forgiveness lay
off 75% of those federal employees shut
down these government agencies is the
legal basis for doing it it's contested
but 6 to3 the current Supreme Court
agrees with me right look at West
Virginia versus zpa I don't know if you
paid attention to this case very
important case if you believe even the
holding of West Virginia versus EPA
which said that there are certain
regulations on coal miners coming from
the EPA that Congress never gave them
the power to pass and so they're
unconstitutional if you believe that
that means literally the overwhelming
majority of federal regulations are also
unconstitutional so this is how you
drive change on the time scales of
History Trump gave us a great Supreme
Court he did pretty much all a
reasonable person could do could
reasonably have done in those four years
great I want to build on that and move
this forward but I've got fresh legs
this time around and I won't be the same
person8 years from now that I am today
after going through it I just won't you
drain the swamp the swamp tries to drain
you back right he's not the same person
today that he was eight years ago cuz
we're all human beings mhm but I do
think it will
take thinking about our movement in
terms of the content of what we want to
achieve rather than just which person is
it going to be right America first does
not belong to Donald Trump it doesn't
belong to me right it belongs to the
people of this country and so the
question is who's best position to take
that agenda forward I think it's going
to take somebody from a different
generation coming in from the outside
with fresh legs to be able to see this
through and I think I'm going to be best
position to do it yeah are so you you've
got a lot of this these agencies right
you you're targeting these guys and look
I think it resonates a lot with what we
talk about on the show these are the
same kinds of things that we talk about
you talked about Black Rock as well so
one of the companies I I don't know your
exact connection to it but Ro roovant I
founded it right so you founded that
company is that something that you're
still currently involved with heavily
off I figured okay have other candidates
in this race it's remarkable people
collecting I think Nikki Haley while
running for president's collecting stock
options off some corporate board that's
that seems unconscionable to it seems a
little bit weird but so you mentioned
Black Rock So as as far as my concern
you go after these agencies they come
after you you go after Google they come
after you you go after Black Rock black
rock just doubled their size of
ownership in there they I I think they
went from 6 million shares to 12 million
shares as of August are you worried
these companies these big investment
firms out there are going to try to get
their hooks in financially and try to
put pressure on you that way of course
how how do you but how do you plan for
that well so here's the way the game
works and so my my most recent book it's
probably the most technical of the books
is capitalist
punishment it lays out exactly how this
game is played it's not if you're a
public company like let's say you take
your company here public which I would
advise you not to do no absolutely but
but but but many many firms do need to
go public for a wide range of reasons
you don't have a choice in terms of who
owns your shares and so it's automatic
it's programmatic that Black Rock State
Street Vanguard and similar firms
through their index funds because
they're not even making investment
decisions right it's just that they have
to they have to have broad exposure to
the market they will end up owning 5 6
7% each 25% 30% collectively and they're
voting their shares in your boardrooms
right so even many of these CEOs who
don't want to be
adopting Dei policies or carbon emission
policies or the goals of the Paris
climate Accords or condemnations of you
know George Floyd's death or whatever
that shouldn't be the business of
companies they're forced to do it
lgbtqia plus # dollar sign dollar sign
whatever it is yeah well the dollar last
dollar sign silent silent I see I see I
see so so that's but but pretty soon
that made the black rock may decide that
that's not Sil
goes yeah so and I actually could give
some specific details on this it when
you said that you're saying that as a
funny aside it's actually true if you
want to take apple the world's largest
company by market capitalization right
we all know Apple they were demanded by
a fringe leftwing group that held a few
shares to adopt what they called the
racial Equity audit at Apple and apple
says no we don't want to do that now I
mean this is not some sort of
conservative company Apple has is off
the ACC is never they don't but they
don't but the one thing if you're Apple
you don't want to mess with is the
talent in your engineering ranks right
you want the best and brightest because
that's how you're competing against the
equivalents in other parts of the world
so they said no thank you very much
nonetheless that Fringe group puts up
this I think it was called color us
United was the one of the nonprofits
that supported no not color us United
col unit is a good one
um I'm trying to remember who it was I
know that we covered it on the show it's
it's it's some some
color is a good one yeah it could be
like colors are us whatever it is
something like that something like that
it was stupid so it was stupid but then
Black Rock and State Street come in and
say we're going to vote and support that
proposal anyway it gets majority
shareholder support at Apple's
shareholder meeting such that Apple's
management team and board then go back
and adopt the racial Equity audit right
so this is nuts actually how about the
equity for the kids in factories uh
building those phones yeah they're okay
with that I
guess can't bring that up you want to
know why actually yeah we used to have
sweat shops now we have like Tech shops
where but but here's here's the other
side of this this isn't it's not just
passive hypocrisy the reason is Apple or
Black Rock can't do business in China if
they dare criticize the practices of the
CCP but if you're also criticizing the
United States or adopting a racial
Equity audit or a carbon emissions cap
then the CCP rolls out the red carpet
right so that's how this game is played
and it is an ugly game so the answer to
your question is how how does black have
all this money it's because if you have
a pension fund or a retirement fund or
401k account they're the ones managing
your money that are investing it across
the board so absolutely I'm deeply
concerned about this and it's going to
take a president it's going to take
leadership in this country that undo a
lot of the rules in the administrative
State you there there's used to be a
rule that said you have to invest
exclusively for profit if you're
managing retirement fund money that has
changed under the Biden Administration
they rescinded what was that what was
known as the what was known as the sole
interest rule at the federal Level under
orisa to now say that you can invest
according to other standards that take
into account factors like climate change
and racial Injustice yeah the government
needs to change a lot of that the
Pension funds need to stop using
political strings attached when they
invest their money but it also take
Market Alternatives yeah to deliver
those Solutions which is why I you know
started strive the most recent business
that I did yeah and so am I worried
absolutely I am but am I sitting around
about it and and no I mean just hold on
I I have to don't get mad at me here but
this is one thing that is you mentioned
another criticism because we have to
give you the ability to answer these
mentioned strive like like eight times
yeah some people would say you're
running for president to promote a
company like they'll say the right
things because and and by the way this
if that were the case I'm not saying is
that is not disimilar from a lot of
people who are in the swamp who run for
president to sell more books totally but
there are people who are going to pick
that up and say are you just promoting
Strife I have to ask you that no
actually I if you look at the probably
we came up in this conversation because
we're talking about Black Rock and we
about big te if you look at probably the
hundreds of hours of my discussion in uh
in the Run for the presidential campaign
my talking about this issue is less than
1% of the total right and I actually
it's a strong suit of yours so it would
be good to talk about it more oh
absolutely I actually this one of the
things that I've picked up is people
know a lot about my policies but people
ask me oh well you've come from nowhere
you know are you are you just are you
just offer
India the whole we would never say
Ohio's not nowhere good parts of it are
I live there for a little while so I can
say that so so I think it's important
that people understand that I have a
track record of taking on bureaucracies
and succeeding and winning but there's a
lot better ways to promote your
businesses maybe be part of your
businesses than to spend 156 million of
your hard earned money and counting to R
ask some people will ask that and people
should ask every question if you're
running for president of United States
every question is fair game but I think
it's important to have somebody who has
actually understood the challenges as
they pop up in the outside world and in
the private sector versus somebody who
has only ever lived within the insular
four corners of an existing political
apparatus which is what most most people
running flip and you know what I just
hey mug Club I hope you guys I think
this is sorry I was looking at the wrong
camera because that's usually my camera
mug club uh today I think we're going to
put all of this out there for the public
because is too too important of an
interview I hope you understand you can
hit the like button and share it and
we'll do some extra content this week um
we'll flip that from where you do have
experience that all of these people in
DC don't right in the private sector
they suck at the government tee but they
would say and I don't think that this is
actually as virtuous as they believe it
is okay no foreign policy experience
right that's sort of that's sort of the
uh the flip I think it's fair and it's
it's a question for people of what they
want I don't have foreign policy
experience I think Nikki Haley in the
first debate she said you have no
foreign policy experience in its shows
my view for most of the other people on
the stage is you do have foreign policy
experience and it shows yeah yeah
exactly what are your experience first
of all show in your bank account yes I
mean some of these people have I mean
just in her case made 8 million bucks in
the period after she left the UN
interesting how a politician leaves
government in debt and goes to being
worth $8 million by starting a military
Contracting firm with your family and
joining the board of Boeing and all
kinds of other things so this is this is
the rot at its worst people who well
she's an aerospace engineer that's why
she's on the bo she was a pratton
Whitney before whole thing but she's a
symptom of of a deeper cancer of
corruption that causes people to adopt
policies including proar policies that
have made a lot of people rich in this
country we said boring I was thinking
Boeing I'm sorry
continue Boeing can be a boring you know
boring that's the the Elon mus
drill so here's what I would say is if
you want the same thing as the last 25
years of foreign policy $3 trillion
spent in places like Iraq and
Afghanistan tens of thousands of
American lives lost that need not have
been lost wars in the Middle East that
have no point no end now seeing the same
thing likely happen again in places like
Ukraine and
otherwise fine go with one of the people
that have foreign policy experience but
if you want somebody who understood and
grew up in an era as a young person
right my peers I wasn't one of them I'm
grateful to my peers who did go serve in
those places but 20 years later now
rightly asked the question of the
Taliban still in charge in Afghanistan
mhm we have a hostile anti-American
regime still in charge in Iraq yeah to
what end it was to literally no end yeah
that's the same wheels that are now
turning again in new conflicts on the
other side of the world most notably in
Ukraine heading into major conflict with
Russia that doesn't Advance American
interests but we're going to see that
proliferate in other places too if you
want an existing foreign policy
establishment that favors War for the
sake of war and a lot of Bad actors in
there who even make money off of
advocating for it fine go with one of
those people with foreign policy
experience but what I do have is a deep
understanding coming in from the outside
to say that now I've made a career
making successful deals for myself what
do you know about a deal everybody has
to win in that deal I've offered the
clearest plan of anybody in this race of
exactly how we will end that Ukraine war
and deliver peace make a hard commitment
that NATO won't admit Ukraine to Nato
yes freeze the current lines of control
I know that drives a lot of people nuts
but these are Russian speaking regions
that have not been represented in
Ukraine's Parliament for a long time in
luhans and dones fine we can do that
deal does Putin get something out of
that deal yes he does but we get more we
require him to pull out of the alliance
with
China that's something you haven't heard
from anybody in the Democrat important
matter of fact it takes an outsider with
clear understanding but without the
baggage of historical experience capture
yeah that's what it's going to take that
to I think keep us out the World War I
mean I think there will be some learning
on the job of course but I think that
what you just said is important you know
we've talked about this where people get
furious will answer people say there is
and by the way not a fan of Russia Putin
at all you know an oligarch and Russ
also not a fan of Ukraine just also by
the way Hitler bad just to be clear
Hitler bad melini bad pole poot bad okay
let's go through all it just make sure
um but when people say like and there is
no part of Ukraine that identifies as
Russian or has ever been Russia you're
like it's not true not kind of does they
kind of do though and you're like now so
you can't just ignore those people
because be Insurgency everybody asked
that question in the Eastern Parts where
they where they actually have captured
land right part of the reason reason why
is that those are Russian speaking
regions that have not been represented
Ukraine's own Parliament it doesn't
justify obviously the military but it is
exactly if we're not looking at it for
take that into account um as we have to
take into account the fact that Ukraine
is not some Paragon democracy I mean
this is a country that's banned 11
opposition parties that's Consolidated
all TV media into one state media arm
does that mean Putin is anything other
than a craven dictator no Putin is a
craven dictator but just because
Russia's bad does not mean Ukraine is
good and we have this false narrative
that we've built up that's what the
existing foreign policy establishment is
good at doing yeah when you get to
George Bush good and evil in Iraq how
much better off the media hated him the
left hated him and when Obama became
president Barack Obama I'm where's code
pink same thing now with Biden I'm like
where where are they remember they used
to they used to protest outside the
white where's where's Michael Moore
right he's out there waving a Ukrainian
flag I'm a second this this is a very
clear case where these are Bad actors
against Bad actors and I'm not saying
movement has actually been are more
effective in securing peace than any
other left-wing peace proace is there
any question at this point like everyone
acknowledges the economy right as far as
Donald Trump okay you have because you
have eight years of Obama then you have
three years I he kept us out of war and
he grew the economy right excellent
president he didn't have any foreign
policy experience as well way the
funniest part man for that first debate
is like Mike Pence saying that we don't
need a rookie on the job the only reason
that guy ever got anywhere near the vice
president wasz some guy who didn't have
any political experience who was a
rookie put him in that job and then
touting that experience is laughable but
again as I've said it I've that's not
the real reason he was he was put there
because Donald Trump wanted someone who
made him look even taller he's like that
was his greatest qu I I'm like Mike
Pence is just not big fans of Mike Pence
especially you talk about talking points
on that stage every single line is
rehearsed and then you can see sometimes
where he looks out like a kid who just
told a joke but it's inappropriate
because in front of adults like this
joke didn't land man um I just wish that
people would be more authentic can we
now can we delineate though and we've
talked about this um obviously in the
last uh the last couple of weeks the
last week or so with Israel Hamas yeah
um there's a big difference between
Ukraine and Russia big difference uh in
that Hamas is a terrorist organization
where the extermination of all Jews is
in their Charter uh and I don't
necessarily Israel matters to our
national interests more than Ukraine
does yes they do they as a matter of
fact they certainly do matter to our
national interest now that doesn't mean
that um there isn't an argument to be
made and we ran the numbers uh if we cut
the funding to all of the Nations uh
with you know who we provide foreign a
to and by the way those numbers are
always very low estimate when you
actually understand also the uh the
incentives uh and Israel as well that
they would come out ahead because we
fund a bunch of people who want to wipe
them off face of the map or help Israel
a little bit and cut money anyways to
places like Iran let's the analogy
you're Dr is interesting when Elon has
drawn this analogy with respect to
electric vehicle subsidies where if you
got rid of all electric vehicle
subsidies Tesla comes out ahead because
unit economics actually work well that's
because they've sold too many Teslas
that's why they don't get the subsidy
anymore I think it's after 250,000 sold
the subsidy goes away like oh so I sold
good cars and the unit economics are
just are just more solid in terms of how
they're how they're running the
operation so here's here's what I would
say I think that this is a moment right
now when we're having this conversation
now where we need rational cool-headed
responses to ask yes how do we support
Israel's own right to its own National
self-defense as Israel is fully entitled
to what happened what Hamas did was
barbaric it was wrong it was inhumane it
was medieval in its nature Israel
absolutely has the right to National
self-existence and to fully defend
itself that's a decision for Israel as
to how they go about doing it and our
job is diplomatically in terms of
intelligence sharing in terms of limited
circumstances of munition support that
is our job as a partner and Ally at the
UN tell the UN you're not going to draw
some false equivalence between Israel's
defense yeah exactly all that nonsense
oh it's the most ridiculous thing most
ridiculous hey CE I was but I was just
raped though yeah but now it's a ceas
fire exactly selective timing of this
our job is diplomatically to stand
against all that nonsense but I don't
want to be one of these people shrieking
I mean Nicki Haley was screeching on air
finish them you know with a vague
reference to almost Iran was what she
invoked right before she said that and
then you talk about Mike Pence just do
it it's like it's like a Nike finish
them is from like Mortal Kombat yeah
exactly just do it is like a Nike slogan
so they're like misappropriating
corporate slogans as though that's our
forign Lindsey Graham what he said
something equivalent to this now fa I
did say kill kill every last one Hamas
absolutely every last member of Hamas
and that's Israel's decision to make and
so Israel's making those decisions I
trust them to do the right thing but we
have to be very careful not to sleepwalk
or emotionally Outburst ourself into
another broad regional conflict that in
the Middle East that the US is in meshed
in with ground troops or otherwise this
is when we've made our worst foreign
policy disastrous mistakes in the past
so if I'm talking to be I would say
listen up we got your back mhm you're on
the right side of this don't let anybody
stand in your way from defending
yourself and we've got your back on that
but my advice to you would be that we've
made some of our poorest decisions in
the wake of real disaster that was your
911 we had our 911 here and we entered
disastrous multi- deade commitments in
places like Iraq and Afghanistan and 20
years later it did not do us an iota of
good there's a little bit of a
difference though I will say and so just
be careful be careful but if you're
comparing it as a percentage of the
population I think it would rough times
you know what it was 20 to 30 something,
Americans and they live right there and
it's never you know they but here here's
all I would say is though let's say you
know as as as awful as this would have
been as 30 times as many people died on
911 as they did and Canada did it well
and going to but going to Iraq yeah
still has nothing to do with that right
right so we I'm just making the point
that we make we've made some of our
worst decisions in response
to emotional reactions to really truly
disastrous things that needed to be
dealt with targeted response get rid of
Bin Laden get rid of the Taliban
absolutely could get rid of get rid of
al-Qaeda hiding in the caves the people
who are responsible for this which by
the way was a far more complicated story
than the US government leted out until
the Declassified files came out 20 years
later go actually get the real job
done rather than using an emotional
response to do something that literally
might be an thogonal objective but in
the mental Haze and in the mental fog of
War we've made some of our worst
decisions so of other countries in their
history that's Israel's decision to make
but my job as the next US president is
to look after American interests and I
do not think we want to be entrenched in
another long drawn out us involved
Regional broad conflict in the Middle
East that would not Advance American
interests but there are easy ways we
ought to support Israel diplomatically
with intelligence sharing I mean heck we
don't even have an ambassador to Israel
right now confirm an ambassador to
Israel in Egypt and other countries
where we don't have confirmed
ambassadors right now we start with like
no money to Iran at all oh absolutely
and no money to
Hamas exactly there there's but even
indirect Aid to Hamas that's actually
been going through in the name of
humanitarian or otherwise deport anybody
in this country who has had any ties to
Hamas or otherwise extradite them to
Israel so there are things we ought
absolutely but there's also some things
that nobody else is talking about that
we ought to be talking about we have to
make sure that we oversee full phase out
through the monitoring and agreements of
Iran's nuclear program but what the heck
are we thinking with the Biden
Administration with some Republicans
cheering it along talking about nuclear
technology transfer to Saudi Arabia yeah
we should not want nuclear proliferation
of any kind yeah in the Middle East
definitely not in Iran but not in Saudi
Arabia either and yet nobody's talking
about that right now so I think we this
is a moment for levelheaded rationality
rather than emotional knee-jerk response
and now it's a cool thing right it's
what the cool kids do criticize the Iraq
War 20 years ago in either party it's
the cool easy thing to do cuz it's long
past and there's no consequence to you
to do it I'm not patting myself on the
back I was in college at the time but I
was against the Iraq War then I had a
bunch of other hairbrain ideas that I
was dead wrong on but that wasn't one of
them yeah and that was a leftwing
position then even though I wasn't on
the left I consider myself a Libertarian
back
then but now is it's easy to do that now
but the hard part is in the thick and
the Heat of the Moment to make sure you
don't make that same mistake but it's
not going to to Iraq it might relate to
Iran or a broader regional conflict in
the Middle East and that's the moment to
think rationally MH how do you do the
right thing in supporting Israel to do
what it needs to do to defend its
National self-existence but at the same
time as the US look after our interests
to make sure that we don't accidentally
tripwire ourselves into some large
protracted conflict in the Middle East
now is the
moment to think with that level of
clarity and reason rather than what I
see as really lazy responses from all
over the political Spectrum the far left
trying to create this false moral
equivalence between Israel and their
enemies that's wrong but you got people
in the old neocon right that have no
muscle memory other than just
effectively pounding the drums for war
without asking the question of the why
we're doing exactly what we're doing and
so back to the question of foreign
policy experience I don't think somebody
with the foreign policy experience
record of the last 25 years should be in
charge of making those decisions I think
it should be somebody of my generation
coming from the outside and in this race
that's me when the track record is bad
it's not much of a track record I do
believe kill every single last one of
them as far as it relates to Hamas
doesn't necessarily by the way they
don't need our money to do it but they
certainly need our our moral support uh
I think you had a follow up the only
thing I would say there is is just be
careful to think that's not the end of
the road there because Hamas is just a
client of broader forces that are
wielding them like Hezbollah so sure
it's the Taliban Story the Taliban 20
years later still now in charge yeah but
you know what when they when they kidnap
your women and children and cut off
their heads it's a good start it's not
and I don't mean that irrationally I
mean Hamas look this is in their it's
different it's in their Charter right
and they're right there and if you look
into the history what's but Hamas 2.0 or
whatever you know get it could be Al you
get Isis we just have to be careful
think and tell ourselves these false
Illusions because it made us puff our
chest and feel good about ourselves to
actually ask the question of what job
are we getting done what is the mission
we're getting done what matters and then
go and have confidence about what we're
actually doing and understand what we're
not doing or else you're going to tell
yourself false myths as we have for the
last 25 years that have led us astray so
that's just I think we have to be really
I think in the Hamas case it's a little
bit different just a little bit because
uh it can't really get much worse unless
you're just talking about more money as
far as the ideology as far as what they
have done to the Jews as far as what
they've said they will continue to do
this is like an Isis like organization
it's as bad as it gets and there is no
end there is no possible if it was
someone who you thought could sit at the
table there could be they could be
reasoned with it's no exterminate all
Jews that includes women and children
we're going to put our weapons cashes uh
in our schools so that we can actually
have our own commit war crimes on both
sides yeah it's dead wrong and I agree
with you on Ukraine Russia same thing
even looking back very different
situation than we're correct to stand
with Israel in terms of our funding of
their national self beare there's that
we should for for Ukraine so this is
related to foreign policy but you I I
said you had kind of like your moonshot
moment you you made a a claim on China
and Taiwan that I wanted to dive into
where you kind of laid out your solution
for the problem and part of that was to
kind of reduce our dependence on Taiwan
for chip manufacturing right and you
said by the end of your first term that
was that was a lot of people may not
have understood how lofty that was but
that is an incredibly lofty goal that a
lot of people would say is not even
practical is what what made you think of
that and why was that something that you
thought could get done I guess would it
be about five years roughly at the end
of your first term so I think it's
achievable if you look at just the
trajectory of what you're looking at in
terms of the tsmc plant in Arizona the
Intel plant in central Ohio where I'm
from today but that's been a disaster in
Arizona though the tsmc oh so far but
part of the reason part of the disaster
nature nature of this is it's not money
which is what we pretend the problem is
and then we shower a bunch of crony
money in the nick name of a chips sack
that's really just a green New Deal in
chips clothing which works well with
American cars but yes yeah I mean it's
funny how this pattern repeats itself
but it's actually a skills shortage
right right so I think one of the things
we should focus on is bringing some of
those skilled workers from Taiwan over
here but then also training more
Americans for the knowhow of how you
create sub 10 nanometer semiconductor
chips right those are the Leading Edge
ones at at at really the front lines of
this but it can't just be an in strategy
I love onshoring and I would love for
that to be the long run steady state
quicker ways to do this as well broader
agreements with South Korea and Japan I
mean Samsung is still further along than
any compan is in the US right even
though you tsmc is still further along
than Samsung so if we're serious about
decoupling our dependence on China or
Taiwan we have to take an all of the
above approach and I think that's what's
different than a lot of people who might
share My Views but just stick to
onshoring alone yeah I love onshoring
but Al Shoring has to be something that
we complement that with and so if you
look at the totality of what's possible
there right and then you provide Market
access to the you know Samsungs Etc of
the world here to build here Etc
Japanese companies as well that I think
is a reasonable achievable path to 5
years from now having basically achieved
near total Leading Edge Advanced
semiconductor Independence which means
that China's not going to have an
economic gun to our head if they choose
to Annex Taiwan doesn't that gun just go
straight to taiwan's head like do do we
worry that they go like oh wow we're
kind of we're kind of up creek here
well well Taiwan should be focusing on
defending itself right now and I would
say in the meantime the US should run
one Destroyer through the Taiwan
straight every week we should absolutely
work with India to have an ability to
block the Andaman Sea and the malaka
straight that's where China actually
gets its Middle Eastern 60% of its
Middle Eastern Oil supplies or 60% of
all its oil supplies which come from the
Middle East come through that straight
so there's a there's a range of things
we need to be doing I love the Second
Amendment here how about the Second
Amendment in Taiwan China's deathly
afraid of anything that resembles a
second amendment put a gun in every
Taiwanese household taiwan's government
could train them how to use it so there
are elements of what calline I mean
absolutely that's another thing we
talked about uh last week it's that's
something they at least have a civilian
trained military so and so it's not it's
not the whole solution but it's at least
a step better than imagine if those
people were carrying like a lot of
people here in Texas at that music
festival when people say what a good guy
hey yeah it abely it'll certainly even
the odds when fortnite hangliding in KN
that these people are and keep in mind I
was raised in Canada which is a very
silly place I'm ashamed uh and no one
there uh owns so the second amendment
was created for a very specific purpose
and it works right okay when you're
talking about foreign Invasion autocrats
invading even your own government
invading that's what it was designed to
do that's not you know and then and then
I say something like this and then CNN
will try to press me a million times
isn't isn't didn't you claim your Taiwan
deterrence strategy was just putting the
Second Amendment in Taiwan no I didn't
say that but it's part of a broader view
of taking what you think of a porcupine
strategy to keep Taiwan on its own feet
taiwan's spending less than 2% of its
GDP on military right now I mean that's
less than the NATO commitment Taiwan
should be spending five plus percent of
GDP on Military which is why I love
Israel as a partner they actually spend
for their own National Defense that's a
good friend and a good Ally so when the
US is clear about what our objectives
are then absolutely right now and people
forget this the Republican Party these
people are such Jokers the the current
US posture towards Taiwan is strategic
ambiguity right yeah the one China
policy is the policy of both parties
right now as we speak I don't know if
you guys remember this when Donald Trump
won the election he picked up the phone
when his phone rang from the Taiwanese
president he was laughed at by both
parties violating diplomatic protocol
yet that's the same GOP that somehow
says that we somehow stand with Taiwan
we don't recognize its existence as a
nation so I say out with the crap let's
focus on reality
we will defend Taiwan at least until we
get semiconductor Independence at which
point we can then return to the status
quo like exactly what it is right now
return to that five years from after
we're semiconductor independent we're
let clarify I think a lot of people miss
this you are saying that you would
switch a stance to we are officially
defending Taiwan as opposed this moral
ambiguity then when we achieve
semiconductor Independence we'll go back
to what status quo is which is kind of
like will we won't we the the entire
Republican establishment too everybody
but we're strictly better off then and
by in the meantime we should fortify our
homeland defenses cyber defenses super
EMP defenses border defenses nuclear
missile defenses Taiwan can spend more
of its own military spending on GDP
we've been running destroyers through
the Taiwan straight shanping would have
to be an idiot to invade Taiwan in the
meantime to have that economic gun to
our head forget about it we're
independent and afterwards we're in a
better position and taiwan's in a better
position than they've ever been so be
more aggressive in the interim and then
go back that's I think the key point
that people Miss they made it sound like
you were going all right see you Taiwan
as inter what somebody else's super pack
is saying in a in a mail flyer about me
and that's what this this whole process
of politics is so badly broken but this
is what I've said at every step of the
way upgrade from the status quo and then
return to the status quo but upgrade giv
Taiwan some lead time to start getting
their act together and allows us to get
our act together we could pull in
Afghanistan and maybe leave one of those
destroyers in the straight we just
forget has a few pallets of cash and the
wi what do you say to somebody's
critique though and and I don't dislike
this strategy my my strategy is to go on
the defensive for Taiwan period we are
going to defend Taiwan what I'm saying
but I understand no no no I understand
that but somebody would say like look
China right now they can save face
because the United States isn't
necessarily kind of Bo up and saying
we'll defend Taiwan Strate strategic
ambiguity is just a term for all of us
we all know that if China invades Taiwan
we're coming to the aid and so is you
know South Korea and Japan right I think
we all kind of understand that's likely
I don't I don't think I mean at at a
time where we're running low on
Munitions right we got got Ukraine Got
Israel
we're running low on our Naval capacity
I don't think that China sees a scenario
right now automatically that the us is
going to be in a position to defend
would you say that they normally say
that clearly what's that would you say
that they normally do normally outside
of the Ukraine conflict right now and
outside of Israel that policy I would
say 4 years ago they did okay so you're
saying it's the our Naval capacity we
have this silly thing called the divest
to invest program where decommissioning
ships in the South China Sea so there's
a lot of re our economic dependence on
China has only gone up over the last
years and if we depend on China for our
other modern way of life the f35s that
we make in this country depend on China
for their parts so things have changed
and so I do think that the Diplomatic
Clarity not strategic ambiguity
strategic Clarity that we will defend
Taiwan that's actually really important
okay especially because the situation
change no that's a good answer for it
because I've heard critique and I wanted
to kind of understand your position I
actually yeah and I actually really like
that answer and by the way Navy was
fantastic till the Village People
screwed it up for the rest they really
I'm regardless of regardless of partisan
partisanship I think most people in this
country will agree definitely most
Republicans and a lot of Independents
and some Democrats too will agree with
the position that I just laid out to you
what I don't know is are they going to
be able to hear it you know who else
will agree yeah Japan yeah absolutely a
l understand it's just a h a hop and a
skip away so a lot those those economic
drivers right are big where they would
say oh okay this makes sense so now we
have some lead time because look it
would be completely unrealistic to think
that the United States never has an
interest especially after coid to
achieve some type of semiconductor
Independence or at least capabilities
right as far as scale they know that and
they're saying okay this gives us some
lead time where we're not just worried
about being wiped off the face of the
map okay we can Now understand what our
agreement is hey you know what reaching
your NATO spending when we're talk is is
is a good start that's right um and uh
yeah that that's very very different
from the way it's been portrayed which
is hey Taiwan uh we're going to stay
ambiguous until we have our
semiconductors and then buy y that's how
the media portrayed it and I think it's
a very important important
differentiation to make because a lot of
people are not aware of how that also
ties into Japan look this is something
we have to talk about this the thing
that's frustrating in in this process is
it's it's a it's a game it's a
distortion about what gets I love these
formats right here in this discussion
and I I was thinking about this in the
flight over because it happened in a
different context earlier today the
future is going to be media that looks
like this long form we're able to
explain ourselves go directly to the
actual listener right but right now
we're in this intermediate era where
very few people are doing this kind of
format I'm doing this I'm doing this the
whole campaign was based on this but
we're doing this in an era where the
Legacy Media is still relevant so what
do they do they're going to come in and
I don't know what it's going to be in
this conversation but they're going to
come in pick something we've said here
completely take it out of context but
that's the projection that still much of
the generally older Republican primary
base still gets served to them so we're
in this intermediate transition phase
where 10 years from now that Legacy
Media is going to be far less relevant
if not gone but this is going to be the
way of the future but now we have this
intermediate version of this where we're
having a long what hour hour plus hour
and a half discussion now that needs to
be and The Listener who's gone through
this is going to be listening to the
whole thing in full but the average
person sitting in Iowa that's only
getting their news from cable news and
the newspaper they read is getting some
purposefully distorted clip because some
guy in the opposition research Camp of
Nikki Haley's campaign and Ronda sz's
campaign actually it's not going to be
their campaign it's going to be their
super pack that the super pack is this
and is watching what they're going to
distort from what came out of this
conversation and they have some paid
historical repeat player relationship
with some Third Rate publication that
calls itself a newspaper and that's
exactly that's exactly the way this game
on CNN or Fox News will be a clip of you
saying I VC Jews hate kill Taiwan and
they'll say there you go made by AI made
by AI exactly American or not you decide
back exactly all right well I think and
I know that we've gone uh over time it's
v224 uh.com and people can follow you on
X can you okay tell people how to we
have it in the lower third VC what what
G ramaswami so what's the G is that your
middle name that's my middle initial
because because VI ramaswami is already
taken on the Twitter handle really how
many are there is it like Scott Smith I
mean it's like you know if you go to
India there's not not quite like a Scott
Smith but it might be like a Scott you
know Crowder Crowder there there are a
few of them that's like uh th what's it
Thiago Silva is like John Smith in
Brazil I've know so many braz
known thank you so for time FKS your
coms uh your feedback because you're a
big sample size and uh hey I really do
appreciate that you have the uh the
fortitude to do this a lot a lot of
candidates are afraid you know this is
going to be unedited and yeah that's
that's how I like it yeah thank you
brother thanks man appreciate it
[Music]
guys
[Applause]
[Music]
you're
Str that's what I
[Music]
know
spe